25 years ago this was kind of a rough
Street and you definitely think twice
about walking it alone at night but
since the 90s crime in San Francisco has
gone way down and not to San Francisco
or California but across the entire
country nationwide the crime rate is
almost half of what it was in 1990 one
thing is no one knows exactly how or why
it has happened most experts say it's
not one single thing but a combination
of factors here are just three plausible
explanations first mass incarceration
we've been jailing more Americans at
record rates and crime has gone down and
you might think well that makes sense
you're locking up more criminals so of
course there's less crime out there on
the streets happening and some extent
you're right the Brennan Center for
Justice says that mass incarceration
accounts for a slight drop in property
crime since 1990 things like robbing
houses stealing cars and so on but the
Brennan Center says you can actually
attribute the drop in violent crime to
mass incarceration for a few reasons one
is that increased incarceration has
meant that more nonviolent offenders
have gotten locked up which obviously
doesn't have a big impact on violent
crime and the Brenden center's numbers
show that increase incarceration doesn't
even necessarily deter crime which might
help explain why in some large states
like California the prison population
has decreased and crime has still gone
down so obviously jailing more and more
people doesn't explain why crime has
gone down another theory new police
strategies in the 90s increased funding
put more police officers on the streets
and some argue that those numbers helped
reduce crime but others say the evidence
isn't totally consistent in San Diego
for example there were no extra police
officers and yet crime still went down
there then there's police strategies
like broken windows which targets
low-level crimes and misdemeanors things
like selling loose cigarettes on the
street or smoking weed out in the open
the jury's still out on how big of a
role that helped play and reduce crime
finally the introduction of something
called CompStat definitely seems to have
had an effect ComStat basically allowed
police officers to
measure crime stats and target specific
neighborhoods and crime for the first
time starting in the 90s no matter what
it's likely that police did play a role
in the crime drop but that's not the
only explanation
the third big factor the economy the
idea is that when more people have jobs
there's less crime as unemployment went
down in the 90s crime also went down and
as unemployment went up in the 2000
crime also saw a small increase it gets
complicated though when you consider
that the recession in 2008 didn't
actually lead to an increase in crime so
what about income as per-capita income
grew in the 90s crime decreased in fact
the higher the average income in the
state the lower the crime rate but more
money could mean more incentive for
criminals like in neighborhoods that
have a big economic disparity so
obviously the crime drop is pretty hard
to explain and there's a whole bunch of
other theories people drinking less that
our access to abortion decreased crack
use Obama mania making folks feel good
in 2008 our aging population and less
exposure to lay yep lead so what do you
think is behind the drop in crime let us
know
back in the 1960s our incarceration
rates were the same as Europe's and if
you think there's just more crime here
that's not true either
our crime